I'm Charles Pugh I vouch on our and
we'll be talking about the unity and the
integration with the world home language
okay I think most of you have been you
know we are here last year you know we
made a pretty nice the more about unity
so we are going to give you kind of the
state of well the package unity link
kind of give you the vision of how we
see it in long-term and integration in
the world we know the world from product
and what we plan to do with that so that
will be first part of the talk and I'll
probably give a short view of you know
the integration from the unity side and
then I like will take from there and
talk about the you know unity from the
Mathematica Wolfram language size and
all the nice demo as such you know he
build on or that people build which
unity okay so first I mean most of you
here are not the world from technology
on the warm technology stack essentially
so I'm not going to go in detail you
know about on what we have but it kind
of just try to give you the edge of what
will bring to the unity side essentially
so one first thing is to know that you
know we have a terrible firm language
but you know we are not going to say to
unity developer which essentially you
see shop too wide the coding or from
language so that's not the main
objective even though you will do that
there and we'll show actually how you
can write some code you know somewhere
from language code and we load it if the
kernel is running behind the scene what
we think about more is the world from
language or the world from product to be
a support and extension of the Unity
engine so depending of what you are
doing you know if you're the
professional game developer or somebody
work indication to teach people how to
learn to do game development I can use
unit and you can use the Wolfram
language and unity together to kind of
ease your work so let's suppose you are
you know you're a teacher right you know
we start to teach our you know high
school kid game development just the
basic you know how to do this sample
pandalus if you want to do that with
unity you have to write AC shop code so
you have to see it teach them c-sharp
you know that we take them
around all that and such but you can
easily just take the Wolfram language
have the unity link and easily in one
day you know learn the basic about the
word firm language and be able to make
your simulation opportunity so that's
kind of the idea you know if you are
doing education if you are professional
you can use you know the set of
technology we have to your pipeline
government pipeline from you know
starting in a design to you know fine
art testing and you know q QA Quality
Assurance of your product because with
the unity link you hopefully have a full
control of the Unity game engine so
during that process I mean you know
having that full control of the
integument and mean you can do Quality
Assurance somebody can you know
essentially can build a simulator from
the Wolfram language you actually P you
again you can monitor how people play
again so that's kind of the idea where
we are going to say social the Wolfram
language is more a product an object on
top of unity it's not really a language
where we hope that people are going to
sit on the velop inside unity with that
okay I hope that gives you a general
idea so on the other side when you know
you I would from language user I guess
most of the people here you know what
you gain to actually use them you know
unity link right well interesting is
that you need to provide you an
environment is simulation environment
so essentially let's suppose you decide
to simulate the pendulous or something
physic you can sit down you know build
your model is no the PDE so cheating and
soviet return dissolve and half graphic
undo the animation or you can just call
unity you have a physic engine behind
the scene well it's not realistic
simulation but it's close to what you
need to do some of the example i like we
show will actually demonstrate that so
you can actually directly tap on unity
use the physic engine you know and happy
feedback in Mathematica that's one
aspect and in the word form language or
currently you know word fun product we
don't yet have animation
you need to have a whole unguent
component there so you can use it for
animation you have a jump of virtual
reality right which our reality
augmented reality so it's already there
it's you know our platform so you can
use it if you're well firm user you want
to do something related to VR to just
unity to give you the link and it's a
lot of more or a pop you know portion a
letís so that's roughly the idea about
you know how we envision and see the
integration between unity and the world
from language and that's slightly far
from the coding and development but just
to give you an idea so now I will just
give you a short demo from the unity
point of view and then after that we do
from the world farm side okay so you
know we always think about you know how
you start so if your unity developer
usually you just want to you know
stature unity and Lodi so here we'll
take a you know let's take the exist I
return of the analytic and I will just
create a project in unity so that's busy
project so is lodging some packages and
you know only different component so
this is roughly the unity environment so
I will open here a package which we call
the you know what fun package is the
unity package which essentially contain
all the component to do the integration
so what we did is that we omitted
everything there as soon as you just
take that package on drop it
oops drop it inside unity assets if I
manage to click on it
what's happen and twisting that one show
your white maybe do let's see if I can
do a copy and paste
question twisting so still well
interesting yep twice it's a bit nope
that's I don't know oh you managed to do
that
perfect those are the magic
so essentially you click on it and then
it automatically load you know all the
component you need so from script to
standard you know extension to the
editor and what he does behind the scene
is actually check your machine if
Mathematica is there and connect to it
and actually you can actually turn it
off you just preference so Hafiz
speaking you sit down there he told you
okay he loaded and he check all the
notebook so essentially this is
connected to a kernel static kernel
behind the scene since the assume that
in your project you want to use warm
tools and one way to see it is on top
layer you have now a menu called welcome
so the first part of the menu construct
you know game object constructor for
example you can say keyboard what it
does is behind the scenes call you know
the world farm engine here in the kernel
and then tell him okay give me the
keyboard to keyboard we have in the
language so you have it the switch in
the scene so there's the cube you can
pick another object the spiky that one
at least we recognize that that's our
object freeze there
since you know a game object is a
mesh-like you know any component in
unity also the circle I mean you also
have the 2d object which actually
generally embed it in 3d and in the 2ds
in the 3d two we have volume you know
imaginary Rohan
a general instance of all the primitives
in the 2d you also
have all the standard 2d what we call
our standard graphic primitive listed we
embed them in 3d automatically so the
last two section for example are you
know some more integration we do so for
example if you say you want the language
this essentially created a game object
instance you can actually call in you a
c-sharp script directly to actually call
unity and what we try to do is to
provide you essentially different
connection so for example you have a
whole authentication and connection to
the cloud so you can actually do your
evaluation directly to the cloud if you
have the white authentication and credit
or to a remote computer or to a local
one the local one is by default or you
can also use the different resource we
have Fino here we have a data drop so
you can for example have a data drop
there you put the ID and for example use
that data drop to actually track you
know everything you have seen for
example when you know the session start
you switch between session or such so so
this is what kind of give you a liturgy
of the integration we are trying to
bring to the unity side so you can even
stay stay in unity and actually use that
and the rest is essentially in the
different kind of interface if you think
about evaluator in the front end side so
you can start it if content for example
here you'll automatically generated
fountain from that from that kernel if
it actually does that the notebook is
somewhere so we open the front end which
is content to that Colonel I can analyze
our search so anyway this is kind of the
general idea of what we plan to do in
this you know on the unit side we can
actually add more asset more tools for
you I will later less continuous so the
Wolfram language sighs hi I'm Alec i'ma
show more about the backer side of doing
out the Ewing alright it's my closest
okay so first I'll give a quick overview
of beauty and Union wink now I should go
into some real examples of how you can
use it and a certain game or project so
first some core concepts we had the
scene the scene is a 3d environment
where all your game objects exist a game
object are all the objects in unity that
actually today I test containers for
components where components actually do
all the real functionality so you have a
scene full of game objects that have
components then each component they
actually control things like lighting
physics audio and rendering a pretty
much anything you can think of you can
use some of you needs default components
or can even write your own using C sharp
they're also assets assets are any files
that you can use within your game and it
exists within the scene but in the asset
folder alright so here's a little
summary of that so you have the scene
scenes can't aim game objects each game
object can contain multiple components
and components can reference assets
within the asset folder alright so
here's a quick overview of the actual
interface on unity so we see on the left
here we have the game objects in the
scene Center we actually have the scene
view on the right we'll see the
components of the selected game object
and then at the bottom we have our
assets folder all right so let's I
should get started so first it's called
needs unity link it's already been
called now so I won't do anything but
it's already been loaded then we want to
open a new unique project first a unity
open and then automatically open nudee
so here again I want to go and create a
new project new opens ok there's set the
name location turn alikes off alright
and create project now I've actually
create the project and it'll load the
Union link package and it or the Wolfram
assets package so you can see it made
the project now it's importing the
Wolfram assets and it should appear down
here and there they are so I can go
ahead and test see if it's working we
can try to find all the game objects in
the scene I see it returns the
directional light and the main cam
which I can see over here on the left
are our two objects in the scene alright
so now the different functions for you
d-link can be broken up into three
different sections you have the create
functions which are for creating
different unity objects then there's
also the find and delete so we'll start
with create here so here you can create
a new scene and give it a name so you
create a scene and it's already saved
down here and we can see the scene name
up here and the upper left go ahead and
create a game object from some geometry
so here we call polyhedron data with the
Alpha spiky and I create a game object
from that and see that added to the
scene here I made this a little bigger
then we also add component or create
components so here I'm gonna create a
light I said I don't give it a game
object it'll just create a new game
object and add the light component to
that so here's that game object I can
see on the right here has the light
component alright and then we can also
create a uni mesh these are four assets
so this is a potential asset so it can
be referenced by different components
and now let's do this year we're going
to actually create it and add it to the
asset folder so I can do that down here
so now it returns unity asset and we'll
see it down here in the assets folder we
actually go ahead and replace the spiky
mesh on a current game object with that
dodecahedron mesh now I can see that
there so now that is using the asset and
the assets folder all right so that's
creation can do similar things for find
we can find the current scene you can
find a game object here we find that
flight game object we can also find
components so on that like game object
we can find all the components on it
here we see it has a transform and a
light component so we can go over here
and check so this light has this
transform up here and the light
component underneath that that's correct
and then we also have with also news we
can find all unity assets in the asset
folder and call that here they receive
that dodecahedron mesh and then the
scene
which are what we have down here and by
default I'm actually ignore the Wolfram
assets alright and finally we had delete
is pretty straightforward so we can
delete a game object like that mesh
there we can delete a component such as
the light on the directional light now
you see that's missing over here we can
delete an asset
okay I'm deleting that mesh asset so now
that's gone and lastly we can delete the
scene so I'll delete the current scene
it's now seen has gone down here and
it's unsaved up here alright now I'll
show a quick example of what you can do
with unity link so here going to do
country selector so be a globe in 3d
that you can spin around and then select
the country once you select the country
I'll highlight it and it'll all show
also display information about it and go
ahead open that up so open up the
project that has the demo in it ok go to
the countries selecting scene alright
now I'll run it here
alright don't go and run our code
alright so now I should be able to
rotate the globe and then click on a
country and now it's loading it and now
see is highlighted and shows an
information such as a name population
and GDP and so on now where for any
country trike and an X and there we go
now let's see how to actually do this
alright so the main workflow here first
you need register as a mouse click then
it gets the intersection with that click
and the globe as a latitude or longitude
coordinates then it calls uni link then
once to do like it's called we have a
function that will find a country entity
create a country mesh from it and then
set the country information so first yes
will call to unity or treatable from
language from unity I can see here it's
only two lines first you just make a
query here it's just a string where we
say the mathematical code we want to run
so here just set country brackets in the
latitude and longitude and then we call
this Wolfram kernel density value 8 on
my query no I'm actually called the
function on the Wolfram language side so
first finding the country so on to get
to a tuna longitude here and get the geo
position we can see that looks like here
so I see it's in New York then we can go
ahead and find a country that's closest
to that or just here the United States
then go ahead and create the country
mesh so once we have our country which
is still in the United States we can get
the polygons from it
are using country data then we can
convert those two regions by
discretizing them so these are in a
latitude and longitude coordinates so we
go ahead and convert those to 3d
Cartesian coordinates using a basic
function so now there's 3d you can see
we rotate around here then we can
combine them using region Union so now
we have our full United States mesh I
never go ahead and create a game object
by passing out the country name and that
combined mesh so we can create that if
we go over here I'll see you added the
mesh there
yeah and that's how the highlighting our
country works you also go ahead and
believe that and I will go over saying
information so it's that the information
it's pretty easy of some tailor country
I'm gonna say our property you want here
you want the full name I can get the
text object or labeled that will contain
that information so here it's this one
over right here you'll see it up here as
the name I can get that we can get the
value of our country name so they
receive Titan America let me go ahead
and set the value of the text on that
label to the name now I see it there all
right so that's the globe demo in a
nutshell here's all the code that's
actually use so here we see this is
what's called from the Uni side that
finds the nearest country which passes
it to here which creates a country mesh
and then sets the country info and it
does some bookkeeping alright our second
example is a 2d one where you draw a
digit and then click a button and it'll
classify a digit from 0 to 9 so we can
see the workflow here first you click a
button then you on you D it will crop
and resize the image then it'll call the
classified digit function on the Wolfram
language side once from language is
called it will get an image data
I'll classify the image and set the
digit label text and color actually go
ahead and demo that real quick I go to
the cause for our scene
runs okay go ahead and run the code goes
with it right now I should be able to
draw a digit they classify I'll show it
digit up here it's trying to cook it'll
be a random color all right so the
workflow for this run over that so now
the first part calling from the wool
from calling the Wolfram language from
unity so we see it's also still two
lines this one's even simpler doesn't
have any parameters to just have the
classified digit function saying you
call it it's once we get that we're
going to go ahead and find the Wolfram
digit draw our component which you can
actually see in our scene right here so
we wanna get this component can see you
properties on it you're interested in
this pixel properties let's go ahead and
grab that so we can see just gonna be a
2d array of ones and zeros can actually
show the entire thing here which ones
and zeros and we can put that to an
image and we see for example here is a
two there can go ahead once here the
image we already have a trained
classifier so we can import that and
then run a classification on it you need
to get our digit once you have our digit
we can find the digit text component we
can set the property of that text
component to be the new digit and we
also set the color to be a random color
so here show us that too yep there we go
and here's all the code so it's pretty
short only about 15 lines to get all
that functionality alright that's it for
demos we also have made this VR demo
over the summer that shows different
functionality and capabilities with the
Wolfram technology stack and unity link
not actually available in the basement
so I can go and try it out all right and
then
[Applause]
okay thank you
well so essentially most of those them
actually with lots that summer and like
essentially work on that and we actually
show it at SIGGRAPH and we actually get
to you know some pretty good feedback
from you know most of the game developer
are so specially the easy use of the
Wolfram language for the component so
you know from now on you know what we
plan essentially we have a bit of
program running you know if you want to
join our big wait and you know we hope
the reason we'll be able to release it
you know inside the warm is that what
fun product essentially and you know I
would like to invite you for the
remaining you know the conference the
little the little link handle which is
tomb over Thursday so if you actually
want to play with it and actually build
things stop by oh you have questions so
will be one our next Thursday I do
budget talk and we also have the
geometry via is exhibit downstairs so
you know stop by on you know talk and
you know there are several people
already using the beta version to build
product there's couple of them or
actually here in the exhibit civil order
which actually already using you know
unity introduction so if you plan to do
so GT you know feel free to stop by and
we'll talk about it thank you any
question yes
so if you inject the game object it's a
real object that you can catch up
physics encoded what what I mean this
says that you you have to call you know
you have to Crane you know a network you
have to actually call it to a execute
right so is what you actually is EQ that
or do that call so one best thing is
that if you use our you know our NOLA
Network you can just call our desktop if
you know if you are using at home or you
can still actually call the cloud right
through our Claudia interface exactly
yeah
so that also we are kind of showing that
cloud interface aspect well you can
actually just call that directly that
they don't really need to have a kernel
running on your device
any other question otherwise thank you